there's never been an issue of
factuality not that I know of with with
Wikileaks there are some other ethical
issues that I you know I think are
legitimate but the amazing thing about
the reaction that journalists have had
since the indictment is the total
inability to see how this relates to the
future of Journalism I mean they're
threatening this guy with 175 years in
prison for doing basically the same
thing that every National Security
journalist does every day you know
they're talking about
conspiracy to
retain National Defense information or
obtaining National Defense information
well that happens all the time I mean
you this stuff doesn't even have to be
classified but we hear classified things
all the time when we do reporting if
that's going to be a crime you can go to
jail for 10 years for and they're going
to enforce that
how can you do reporting anymore and
everybody's all for it